mayor Eric Adams he's not a very good
mayor he's a big lib New York City is
not doing very well under his leadership
but he's also not the worst mayor we've
ever had especially coming after Bill de
Blasio you know I'm a New Yorker by
upbringing and so I care still a lot
it's very sad to see poor old Gotham
descend into crime in Mayhem and Eric
Adam said something the other day where
I felt I had to give him credit where
credits too he said that
when God and prayer and the Bible left
schools that's when the guns came into
schools
so he's trying to make a little knock at
guns in the Second Amendment but okay
I'm willing to overlook that because
he's defending
God in schools that's a very
conservative position very out of step
with the rest of his party so mayor
Adams went on CNN and the CNN lady
grilled him over this she was Furious
she said how dare are you suggesting
that there is no firm separation of
church and state here's mayor Adams's
answer
you also said you implement policies
with a quote god-like approach and said
quote when we took prayers out of
schools gum guns came into schools you
know that those comments alarmed some
people even some religiously related
religious leaders rather who were in the
room a rabbi who was there called it
dangerous well listen let's be clear on
something uh the last words I said after
I was sworn in is so help me God on our
dollar bill we have in God we trust
every president touched a religious book
when they were sworn in uh except for
three
faith is who I am and anyone who takes
those words are stating that I'm going
to try to compel people to follow my
religion no I'm a I'm a Child of God I
believe that Holy I'm going to follow
the law I'm not going to compel people
who believe in whatever faith it could
be of you in the synagogue a Baptist
Church a Buddhist temple I'm in all of
them and that's what was in my my
service just to be clear do you
fundamentally believe in the separation
of church and state from a governing
standpoint no what I believe is that you
cannot separate your faith
awesome
love that this guy this liberal Democrat
has more courage on this very important
issue than many if not most Republicans
in public life
do you not believe in a separation of
church and state very simply goes no
no I don't
good that puts him on the same side as
the founding fathers every American
statesman until the 60s and 70s 1960s
and 70s and every great leader and
Statesman throughout all of history
since the dawn of time
of course not and his reasoning is quite
right he says
faith
is everything to me it informs
everything I do he says I'm not going to
force people to join my denomination or
particular religious View
I'm all for Toleration but
you can't separate me from my faith
and if you can't separate me from my
faith and you can't separate my face my
faith from government because I am the
person in office right now of course all
politics all human conflict ultimately
is theological it has to be that's
always inevitable
the
I've mentioned the writer Matthew
petruzik's excellent way of thinking
about this
politics is on top of morality is on top
of epistemology is on top of
anthropology is on top of ontology is on
top of theology
alter without getting into every
category ultimately
you've got to get down to the question
of what is everything
what
is everything that is resting upon
and that is a theological question
you can't you can't pass a law about
taxes or parking tickets without getting
down to some theological premises
you can't do it it's not possible so
he's he's just being honest about that
and the people who say no we're gonna
have a separation of church and state
no no we don't I don't let my religious
views affect my politics that's what
John F Kennedy said when he was running
for president and he was afraid that by
being Catholic he would lose they said
oh I'm listen yeah I'm very Catholic but
I would never let my Catholic faith
affect anything I do okay so practically
speaking you're not all that Gap like
okay fine Adams is saying no of course
we all do that
and he does it too I love it great great
on him I hope I have Republican leaders
follow this mostly failed liberal mayor
of New York at least on this question
say okay yeah absolutely
and that allows you to be tolerant when
you know what you stand for and you're
being very clear and very open you can
be tolerant of minority religious views
he says I'm not going to go after the
Hindus or whatever and for Buddhists and
try to convert them to my way of
thinking
he's going to tolerate it but
you can only tolerate these sort of
minority views if you have a broadly
established
set of norms and standards that derive
from the that derive from faith and the
majority faith in the country
three years after all the powers that be
attacked and censored anyone who
suggested that covid may be escaped from
a Chinese bio lab called us all crazy
conspiracy theorists more and more
government agencies are admitting that
the virus
most likely came from the Chinese bio
lab but so what the Liberals are simply
claiming that back then the science
suggested that the virus originated in
nature and now they say the science has
developed and shown that it likely began
in the lab no big deal that's how
science is supposed to work right
not quite now that Republicans control
the House of Representatives we are
finally able to investigate and see how
that early scientific consensus
developed and it turns out
it's not very scientific in fact it's
looking
pretty much entirely political
on April 17 2020 here is what Dr fauci
told reporters
there was a study recently where a group
of Highly qualified evolutionary
virologists looked at the sequences in
bats as they evolve and the mutations
that it took to get to the point where
it is now totally consistent with a jump
of a species from an animal to a human
so the paper will be available I don't
have the authors right now but we can
make it available to you
straightforward enough right
sounds like it except what fauci didn't
tell you
is that he was the guy who prompted the
study specifically in order to debunk
the lab League theory that we now know
was almost certainly correct
and that we knew at the time actually
many of us was almost certainly correct
according to the House Republicans and
Democrats investigating fauci this is a
bipartisan Select Committee
quote
the evidence available to the select
subcommittee suggests that Dr Anthony
fauci prompted Dr Christian Anderson
Professor Scripps Research to write
proximal origin
and that the goal was to disprove any
lab League Theory
the select committee found that Dr
Anderson privately did not find the
natural origin Theory particularly
compelling despite saying so publicly
this is how fake news Works whether
we're talking about fake news in the
trump-russia hoax whether we're talking
about fake news in my own recent run-in
with being accused of genocide to the
fake news from Dr fauci in the origin of
covid
the liberal operators who control the
scientific media big Tech and government
establishments work in collusion with
one another
so in the case of covid they concoct the
scientific rationale
which is then adopted by the government
which is then reported on by the media
which is then protected through
censorship of contrary views by big Tech
all to push a conclusion that they had
already reached from the very beginning
a conclusion that was political in
nature then occasionally we find out the
whole thing was a political operation
but only later long after the Revelation
would have had any practical political
effect falsehood flies and truth comes
limping after it in this case well into
Dr fauci's Pleasant retirement
where unfortunately it seems he will
face no consequences for his deceit the
rest of the show continues now you don't
want to miss it become a member use code
Knowles Canada w-les at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]